so my name is Noah work of ruin and I'm
going to talk about games how many of
you play games at all how many of you
play games every week how many of you
play games more than you read novels
more than you watch TV okay it gives me
a pretty good idea okay um uh oh I I am
definitely somebody who's here um as an
advocate for the possibility of games
but i also want to talk about some of
the things that maybe we don't like to
talk about and i think one of the things
that doesn't come up when we're kind of
doing games boosterism is that um a lot
of games kind of feel the same and I'm
not sure I mean what you immediately
think I mean so for example an early
game whether you counted from Willie
higginbottom's version or at ari's
version or whatever is pong or tennis
for two you know this sort of very
simple simulation of tennis or ping-pong
where a virtual ball goes back and forth
and knocks into the walls and knocks
into the paddles and people can move the
paddles up and down right and what's
going on there well there there's things
that you can move as a player the
paddles and there's also collisions
right there's collision detection so the
the virtual ball can run into the
virtual paddle and bounce off it can run
into the virtual wall and bounce off it
can go past the paddle and when it
collides with the edge of the screen
your opponent scores point we might say
another very influential early game oh
this is darker than I thought it would
be so this is an image you'll have to
take my my word for it this is an image
of space war on a game that we can date
more precisely in 1962 at MIT where two
players you know maneuver starcraft
around and fire projectiles at each
other but also are constantly being
sucked in word by the force of a central
star at the middle of the at the middle
of the space and so here we said
add something that'll eat you and pong
was if it was present at all was very
simple right you know pong if something
hits at a certain trajectory it bounces
off another one that's a very simple
model of physics space war has a more
complex model of physics where things
like gravity are actually being modeled
so collision movement physics we might
feel that pac-man is a very different
game I don't if you look at what's going
on in pac-man well you've got collision
you can't run in part in two parts of
the maze and you've got movement right
you can move the joystick like you could
move the paddle like you could move the
spaceship and if you think about more
recent games even the games that seem
kind of innovative a lot of them are
basically a celebration of these same
elements packaged in a new way so if you
think about something like Mirror's Edge
which is a parkour game right but it's
basically a game of movement collision
detection and physics or a game like
calamari dama see right this is a game
where it's a very strange game that I
recommend to all of you right where you
roll things around and you collect more
and more of them and you get bigger and
bigger balls as you collect more and
more things until eventually you're
collecting people's and people and cars
and islands and so on and you start out
with like paper clips alright so how
should we think about this right how do
we think about the fact that there's
something similar at the heart of so
much of what we often think of as a kind
of diverse computer game culture well
genre isn't going to help right we
usually talk about computer games in
terms of genres right there's strategy
games there are first-person shooters
and so on but these games are all in
different genres so that's not how we
can think about this sort of deep
similarity usually the sort of next
level down Oh game analysis is not John
rabe of mechanics right what are the
things that make the game operate what
are the the rules that the player
experiences when they play but again
these mechanics are really diverse from
each other right what's being done
on um is it is quite different so you
know maybe it's something deeper right
maybe that's how we can think about this
similarity and then as as you might
guess right I'm going to this familiar
question which for those of you who
think about digital media kind of comes
up again and again in different guises
which is basically how do we think about
the inside of digital media right so we
kind of know from thinking about other
media some way we might think about
audiences we know from other kinds of
media some ways we might think about
what appears on the surface right what's
the interface but how do we think about
the inside it seems really perplexing to
a lot of people who in sort of the
digital media field right so some people
might say well you know maybe zeros and
ones way oh this is supposed to be on
the cover of Sadie plants book which is
called zeros and ones right so maybe
binary arithmetic is really central
right maybe if we could just get a
handle on the sort of the fact that
things are stored that way maybe that
would tell us something not many people
i think argue that very seriously
anymore I think a lot more seriously
people argue this sort of uncompelled
source code is key if we could just
start interpreting code maybe we would
understand digital media more deeply and
slsa has had a conference on code ARS
electronica has had a conference on code
right you know this seems to be sort of
one of the currently probably still on
the rise models for how we might
understand digital media and it's a
model that I'm resistant toward and I
can think of my resistance probably in a
number of ways but part of it I think is
just personal right like I've you know
worked as a as a you know person in a
research lab and if you came in while I
was editing some code on my screen and
said hey what are you working on what
does that do and I said oh I'll print
the code out for you and you can read it
over lunch right that would be a really
rude answer right that would basically
be a way of saying like go away you're
no because um well as those of us who
create code probably know all too
well one of the biggest ways to get a
software project to fail is to hand it
off from one program or to another right
because code is not self explaining code
is actually often quite you know
obfuscated it and difficult to
understand and difficult to maintain and
we don't even have a good way of reading
our own code after six months often
right so I really think this is this is
a confusion to think that really what we
want to be getting at is the code I
think there are other models that are
going to be more productive so I'm in my
recent book expressive processing what I
try to do is analyze things in terms of
their operational logics right so
sometimes I have had to resort to source
code as a way of identifying the
operational logics that I want to
discuss but there are lots of other
places to get them from right that's why
people write technical articles that's
why people give conference presentations
that's why people produce dissertations
is to have some sort of accurate but
higher level description than the code
of what the code does and that I think
is a good way a good resource for trying
to recognize what the logics are at work
in a piece of software so to say this a
little more concretely for me
operational logics in terms of digital
media are abstract processes used by
authors to communicate to audiences that
can be implemented in many ways all
right so what do I mean by in many ways
right so if you play a game like pong on
the Atari VCS right they the Atari 2600
is it's also known but the first major
home computer game system the collision
detection is actually implemented in
hardware the television interface
adapter for the 2600 knows when it's
drawing things that are touching whereas
you know let's say you're you know a
student being assigned to build a game
in Microsoft's XNA environment there the
collision detection is entirely
implemented in software right it's a
radically different implementation but
the logic right this sort of idea that
is expressed through an algorithm that
virtual objects can touch is the same
and I would argue perhaps
controversially that nearly all computer
games today are about this they're about
virtual objects touching whether those
virtual objects are projectiles or
characters and platforms or whatever now
the usual objection I get to that sort
of assertion is well aren't games also
really about their story and certainly
games often have interesting stories
right so I don't know how many of you
have played prince of persia sands of
time ok so a couple please do before the
jake gyllenhaal movie comes out this
summer right I mean them he may be a
very talented actor he's not Persian
anyway so I then that just sort of makes
me less hopeful than I should be um
anyway so this does have you know a kind
of a quite interesting story about
inevitability and it really in many ways
about the form of the game and the
mechanics of the game but the structure
of the game is this right so there are
all these sort of areas of play
platforming play combat play and then
there are the moments in between where
fiction takes place right and play and
fiction kind of alternate I would argue
that games are really about what you do
when you're playing them and what you do
when you play Prince of Persia is not
the story right Prince of Persia is
about platforms and time mechanics and
so on and that's why it tells an
appropriate story for what it's about
but it's not really about its story and
I would say the same is true of the
half-life series the Uncharted series of
many games that are allotted for their
storytelling they have this structure
where you sort of experience a story
when you're not playing and then other
times when you're playing it's not a
story um and actually I might even argue
this for the current state of
role-playing games which are the closest
to trying to say use dialogue as a game
mechanic and if you're interested in my
argument about current role playing
games I'm actually going to be giving
that on Wednesday I think at noon
so stick around afterwards and maybe we
can figure out exactly where anyway or
maybe actually searching online might be
a better way all right so let's say that
we have these logics right of collision
detection and movement and so on and I
say you know they're basically about
representing objects and objects running
into each other and that's what most
games are about well couldn't we just
use those logics to represent something
else right yeah if this is an algorithm
that's used to represent an idea what if
we repurpose those algorithmic
representations for some other purpose
so I don't know how many of you have
played jason wars passage okay ah so for
everyone but him um I am now going to
like give you spoilers for the game and
if you are someone for who likes to
avoid spoilers I guess you could have
close your ears and eyes for a moment so
passage very deliberately is trying to
take these well-known game logics and
use them for some other purpose and has
this kind of 8-bit representational
style that it uses to kind of foreground
how sort of classic its underlying a
software system is so you play this
character and you can go and I sort of
explore the world and you can go through
these passageways and you can you know
get things that look like the typical
8-bit rewards right I discover this
treasure chest and there's this sort of
explosion of blue and a star comes out
and clearly I'm doing something right
you can also do this right you can sort
of keep going it that way instead of
going down and you can get together with
your love interest right who's also
8-bit and the two of you can travel the
world together but interestingly the two
of you can't go down many of the
passages that one of you could alone
right and this is when you start to get
the hint that the game is maybe about
something other than what it seems to be
about right that it's trying to use
collision detection to represent
something else so you and your partner
go through the parts of the world that
you can reach as a pair and you start to
notice that you know as you make these
movements
you are transforming right so like the
here's a shot of sort of a moment of
transformation and that over time as you
play the game you know your little 8-bit
sprites are becoming love you sort of
not only sort of further along the
screen to the right there also
unmistakeably older even though they're
only 8 bit so you start passing through
these different parts of the world you
keep transforming you keep getting older
and then the sort of you know best known
moment of the game is as you keep
exploring the world this happens right
one of you becomes a tombstone and then
you have a lot more places you can go
again but i think you know most people
end up playing the way that i did and
they just sort of go forward into this
relatively empty checkerboard area until
this happens and that's the end of the
game right so clearly you know roar is
trying to use this sort of traditional
movement collision detection set of
logics to express something about life
and it's kind of a neat trick but I'm
pretty convinced it's not the beginning
of a new genre right it could be that we
would actually redefine these logics we
would say you know collision detection
no longer means virtual objects can
touch collision detection means some
pathways in life are open to you and
others not depending on the shape of
your player character right but even war
has basically started moving away from
this right so like his new game is some
sleep as death which is also a
storytelling game but a storytelling
game that it's only for two players and
it basically is used using human
intelligence to try to allow a lot more
operations than you can get out of this
sort of limited palette that that he
implements in his early games so sort of
my question and the question that I want
to use the next 10 minutes trying to
answer is can we go further right and I
think we can go further in a couple of
ways
one way which is um what gets me billed
as an artist in a scholar is that I'd
region I create things like this so this
is an excerpt from a video about a piece
i did with collaborators first at Brown
University and then there was an
iteration at UC San Diego and there's
been some installation versions of it
and it starts with three short fictions
very short fictions each the size of an
eight-by-eight wall and when they're
projected better each about memory is a
virtual experience and then the player
starts out by reading these texts and
then the text begin to come loose and
you can just watch them come loose but
you can also start hitting them back
with your hand and as you hit them back
with your hand often they go back to
where they came from but sometimes they
go back where other words used to be and
sometimes they break apart if you hit
them too hard or if there's not a good
space on the wall for them to go to and
what happens is you can play more and
more actively and the more actively you
play the longer the kind of memory texts
stay in place but also the more
distorted and intermixed they become and
eventually when too many words are off
the wall at once then all the rest of
them pull loose and collapse and that's
the end of the experience right
like this
and so what this is essentially doing is
using that very familiar game mechanic
right movement and collision detection
but using the movement and collision
detection to try to UM enact an activity
that is thematically related to um what
is going on in the textual material
right so we're not actually taking
action in the fictional world instead
what we're doing is we're doing some
other action as readers and players that
is related to the fictional world and I
think that's one way of going further
right is that we can use these
traditional gameplay mechanics even more
radically than someone like war tries to
use them but I think there's still this
question about you know what about
playing with people right you know what
if we were trying to make games about
people were you actually played with the
people in the fictional world and this
is a course you know the elephant in the
room right is will writes the sims this
is one of the best-selling games of all
time and it's certainly not a game about
collision detection right it's a game
about something else and I think
actually looking carefully at what it's
something else is can tell us a lot
about sort of what possibility space
might be worth exploring as we think
about games about people all right so
this is both one of the most culturally
influential and one of the most
commercially successful games of all
time and yet unlike games like say doom
that are also very commercially and
culturally important there have been
basically no knockoffs there's been no
sort of genre formed outside of the
efforts of the sims team at Max's / EA
and why that is is also I think another
interesting question right okay so
what's going on in the sims for those
who you haven't played basically we
control the home lives of simulated
people in the suburban us right so we
don't when they go to work they
disappear when then we see them again
when they come home and we have to make
sure we get them to work on time
but it's just about home life and you
know there are expansions where you do
things like go out on a date they're
expansions where you can live in an
urban environment instead of a suburban
one but it's it's about home life and
social life it's not about work life or
political life or anything else right
there are many many possible actions in
The Sims right there are lots of things
you can do you can wash the sink you can
make dishes you can take shower you can
urinate right i mean there there are
lots and lots of things you can do in
every expansion pack gives you more
things you can do right when you get an
expansion pack that has a chessboard in
it suddenly all your Sims know how to
play chess the reason they know how to
play chess is because all the animations
and all the other behaviors in terms of
how the simulated world is fected are
bundled up with each object right so
each object is kind of a smart object
that advertises to Sims I can do these
things for you and if you take this
action this is the animation you should
use and so on so this is a shot of the
Edith editor that's actually used for
creating objects and here you can see
something that's particularly important
which is how the particular actions
being edited affects the basic needs
meters of the sims right so you can take
actions that do things like increase
skills or improve jobs or you know
change social relations with other sims
but most of the skill most of the
actions whatever else they do and most
of them maybe only address the needs
meters so basically as you come to play
the sims what you come to understand is
that a simulated person especially sims
1 but I would argue it's the same up
through sims 3 a simulated person is a
set of meters and basically what you're
trying to do in life is keep these
meters from degrading too far right if
you get to the point where you know your
bladder is about to burst or if you get
to the point where you know you are
about to fall asleep on your feet or
whatever you are losing of course there
is a genre of play that's just about
torturing your sims but um we'll leave
that aside for now
um I mean like you know locking them in
a room and setting it on fire or locking
them in a room that just has no urinal
or whatever um so um what are you doing
when you play the sims basically you're
fighting against time to meet needs and
get to your job right so you know the
carpool is going to come in about an
hour oh but I have a shower and I
haven't dressed I'm it eaten Ivan clean
the house I've made the bed you know um
starting to sound really familiar
actually um and um there's this sort of
tension where more expensive objects
satisfying needs better right you know a
better refrigerator keeps food fresh or
longer and the food is more satisfying
but also requires more money to maintain
you're paying more bills to have the
house that will hold all these objects
and so on and so basically the result
for most players certainly for me I
think is it basically the sims is a game
about never having enough time money or
space right and you're constantly
trading off right so what are the logics
of the simp the sim this is not about
movement and collision detection I would
actually argue that the logics of the
sims are also very familiar to us right
for those of you who've played oregon
trail or those of you who've played
civilization or those of you who played
will rights earlier game SimCity right
these are the logics basically of
resource allocation and random events
right so their sources sinks
transformations right I can choose to
turn my sims time into relief for my
sims bladder but it is not that
different from choosing to turn part of
my population to harvesting grain in
civilization right um that these are
very familiar logics these are not
invented for the sims and actually that
is probably why we don't see a genre
emerging around the sims I would argue
that basically it's like Jason Mora's
passage it's kind of a one-off it kind
of says hey you know you could use those
logics that were designed for something
else and you could actually use them to
represent human life but those logics
were never designed to represent human
life and there's kind of one trick to
how
do it and i would say that also probably
tells us why at least for me a
particular story is the best sim story
so this is like there's a story of this
gnome who used to have a very sort of
loving owner and then the owner died and
he was being really abused by the owners
brother but he couldn't reach the phone
to call for help so he went into the
brothers bathroom while the brother was
taking a shower and pushed the
television in igniting a conflagration
and now the brother is also a lawn
ornament like the gnome but that's I'm
not the best same story right that's
just sort of the kind of story you
usually see out of the sims which is
basically the audience for the game
setting up situations and taking
pictures of them rather than the game
actually playing itself according to its
own lodgings now I'm actually talking
about Allison kev how many of you heard
of this a few okay um so Allison kev is
a story of two sims in the sims 3 kev
who has the traits of being I think
insane and inappropriate and something
else and his daughter Alice who is
unlucky and I forget what her other
traits are and they're homeless right
this is a picture of them living on park
benches and as much as possible the
person who kind of posted this story
online so that he was just letting the
sims play themselves they can go into
kind of autonomous know mode according
to the logic of the game right so the
story involves a lot of like a 0 them
sleeping in places that belong to other
people and these other people getting
kind of concerned and upset of Alice
eventually getting old enough to get a
job and using a good chunk of her income
not for financial security but to send
off to charity and and basically it's a
story about resources right when the
sameness tells its own story when it
tells a satisfying story it's a story
about resources about not having enough
resources because the internal logics of
the sims are entirely organized around
resources so what if we wanted to invent
new logics and this is kind of the home
stretch here although I think
starting to be overtime right can I take
a couple extra minutes yeah okay so some
of you may know Michael Matthias and
Andrew Stern's facade project it starts
out where you come to visit the home of
these two despicable yuppies who you
went to college with and introduced who
are now married and their marriage is
going to fall apart horribly before your
eyes but differently depending on how
you interact and there are a lot of
structures kind of built for facade so
there's this drama manager the kind of
tries to sequence the action to have
this new Aristotelian arc there are
these sequencing beats that cause the
the characters to sort of do little
interactive bits with you the inter
actor and then recover when you bring up
other things and so on but there's a
design lesson that actually came out of
this which is that a powerful way of
making games about people is to create
what Matthias and stern called social
games so for example in the beginning of
the facade they're trying to make you
play an affinity game which is kind of a
zero-sum trying to force you to take
sides between them later on they're
playing this therapy game where you're
supposed to be trying to help them come
to sort of greater self revelation about
themselves and this idea of social games
is something that was not explicitly
algorithmically invent represented in
facade it's almost as though you had a
platforming game but you pasted on the
collision detection code into every
single platform that they could run into
right it's kind of hand authored all the
way through is the way that these social
games were represented so um question is
from how would you move this to an
explicit algorithmic representation so
one approach might be the sims 3 right
it has these social situations so when a
houseguest is over everyone behaves
differently then you you don't do you do
things that are different than you would
do in your own house you do different
things than you would do with members of
your own household but the actions are
really atomic there's no connections and
series of actions there's no history
that goes on right you know no one ever
says that time when you came over to my
house and ate the lasagna that was mine
right because the history only exists as
meters and you can't refer to a history
in any sort of meaningful
that's only exists as meters so the
question is can we combine widely
varying play with a fully realized human
situation and especially can we do this
both immediately moment by moment and
over time so actually we're doing an
experiment right now in an unannounced
game that we're calling the prom which
has emo people sort of AV Club people
and goth people who are at a high school
together and you can do things like view
the state of their social network right
so in this case of Edward and Karen like
your level objective and the sort of
social puzzle would be to get them to
date but that turns out to be impossible
because Robert who's good friends with
Edward hates Karen and there are a lot
of things that you could do to kind of
try to change the social situation to
make it possible right so you could make
it so that you know these two just like
each other better or you could make it
so these two like each other less and so
on and you know in the sort of prototype
version that you're seeing images of
here we don't do any sort of like facial
animation but maybe that's appropriate
because like if your email enough you
should be sad even when you're admitting
that you like someone a lot so this is
again another collaboration with a big
group of people and so in essence the
structure of this game is that the
characters play exaggerated social games
the design of these games is actually
inspired both by sort of dramaturgical
analysis which is a you know an old vein
of social science work and fiction serve
you know humanistic and writing centric
evaluation of social games and what
these games exist to do is change social
state and then they chained together
right so somebody asked someone out well
maybe that results in flirting and
flirting can chain to other things or
maybe results of a compliment that can
change other things and then these
particular parts of the social games get
filled out with things from the social
facts database so in this case we could
say that Edward no they get reads
Dostoevsky and in the world at this high
school that is lame right so that's part
of the social facts database
and then games also create history and
reveal history so part of what happens
as you play this game is that not only
are things recorded about how the social
games play out that can then be
connected to future social games but
also you reveal things about the
characters who they are how they became
in the situation's therein as you play
because the game starts with the with
this database already pretty well
populated so there are many possible
paths through social configurations to a
given goal and yet the social
interactions are kind of fully and
concretely realized so and this is just
an experiment right this is just the
sort of thing that we do in our group is
we we try to imagine how you could
create a new game and then maybe
potentially a new genre so the
conclusion of my talk is that I think we
can make games that are really about
people and we can really try to
understand games that are about people
but it will require computer scientists
artists and humanists working together
thank you